[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti avreste voglia di
fare un viaggio con me nel futuro
bene allora vi porto in un posto che
frequentiamo tutti una farmacia
nell'anno 2050 allora io mi calo nel
personaggio voi immaginate me con
trent'anni di più piena di acciacchi che
entrò in farmacia
mi rivolgo non può supplicando alla
dottoressa e le dico dottoressa guardia
nuovamente quella terribile neuropatia
al nervo sciatico
avrei bisogno di un farmaco però
gentilmente non mi dia quello solito
quello che mi causa quella terribile
mitrani alla sonnolenza per giorni
allora la dottoressa con fare il
paziente indice signora le mi sta
dicendo che non vuole un farmaco
tradizionale le potrei proporre una
formulazione attivabile come immaginate
questa idea mi entusiasma chiedo subito
spiegazioni
e allora la dottoressa mi dice con
competenza si tratta di una nano
formulazione che si attiva solo nervo
sciatico
quindi non ha effetti collaterali niente
mal di testa
nessuna nessun altro effetto collaterale
bene signori allora lasciamo questa
vecchietta contenta entusiasta in quella
farmacia nell'anno 2050 e torniamo un
attimino nel presente perché a questo
punto io vorrei spiegarvi come mai
questa scenetta ritrae un futuro per me
verosimile e lo faccio partendo dal
concetto di nanomedicina ossia quella
disciplina che studia nanoparticelle
nano formulazioni ovvero nanoparticelle
capace di introdurre le farmacie
all'interno di una cellula
che nanoparticelle sono oggetti
piccolissimi piccoli come un virus con
corona virus giusto per intenderci per
capire quanto sia piccola una
nanoparticella rispetto una cellula
immaginate il rapporto di dimensioni che
c'è tra una coccinella
tante e proprio in virtù di queste
piccolissime dimensioni che la
nanoparticella in grado di attraversare
le membrane cellulari e trasportare i
farmaci all'interno
bene qual è il vantaggio di questo
approccio
il vantaggio è poter superare le
barriere biologiche che cosa sia una
barriera biologica me lo spiego con
un'animazione
immaginiamo di avere un individuo che
abbia una certa patologia per esempio
una patologia oculare di natura genetica
e allora immaginiamo insieme il fa il
viaggio scusate mi si è bloccato
riproviamoci immaginiamo insieme il
viaggio che debba fare il farmaco per
poter svolgere la sua azione terapeutica
questo farmaco verrà istillato come
collirio nell'occhio dovrà portarsi
nella camera posteriore dove si trova la
retina dovrà trovare il giusto strato di
cellule passare le membrane cellulari
arrivare nel nucleo e identificare il
gene ed a bersagliare wow in un viaggio
lunghissimo capite bene che spesso un
farmaco fallisce non perché non sia in
grado di esercitare la sua azione
terapeutica ma perché non è in grado di
compiere questo lungo viaggio della
nanomedicina fa proprio questo sviluppa
dei trasportatori cioè nanoparticelle
che siano in grado di traghettare un
farmaco all'interno della cellula
ma la nano mi dice la nanomedicina
intorno a noi le nanoparticelle le
troviamo nelle nostre case negli shampoo
creme per il corpo qualunque prodotto
cosmetico ma le troviamo anche in
farmacia in tantissimi i farmaci che
tutti i giorni salvano la vita dei
pazienti come per esempio farmaci
chemioterapici per curare i tumori
ma allora dove sta la novità questa
dobbiamo aspettarci dal 2050 dove sta
all'innovazione bene la scenetta del
futuro vi avevo parlato di nano
formulazioni attivabili cioè farm ai
farmaci che si accendono e si spengono
con uno stimolo come quando viaggiamo un
interruttore per accendere radio una
televisione quello in cui dispositivo
elettronico
bene qual è perché avere dei farmaci che
si accendono e si spengono dovrebbe
rappresentare una rivoluzione per la
medicina
sappiamo tutti che farmaci hanno degli
effetti indesiderati sufficiente leggere
il bugiardino di qualunque farmaco che
avete nella vostra dispensa per leggere
frasi del tipo usare solo dietro
prescrizione medica non abusare del
farmaco questo perché come vi dicevo chi
più chi meno tutti i farmaci hanno degli
effetti collaterali
ma allora possiamo immaginarci un futuro
possiamo immaginarci un anno 2050 in cui
questi farmaci vengono somministrate in
una forma inattiva quindi innocua che
venga poi attivata esclusivamente nella
cellula malata
allora in questa animazione vedete un
esempio di farmaco foto attivabile come
dice la parola stessa è un farmaco che
si attiva con la luce non somministriamo
in questa forma inattiva quindi innocua
in un paziente che avrà una lesione
cutanea che deve essere eliminata bene
il paziente prenderà il farmaco in
questa forma inattiva
dopo di che noi esporremo la lesione
cutanea a una luce laser il punto
irraggiato e soltanto quel punto vedrà
l'attivazione
della nano formulazione foto attivabile
e trattandosi di un farmaco killer
causerà la scomparsa della lezione
qualunque altro un qualunque altro punto
dell'organismo poiché non c'è stata
irraggiamento lanaro formulazione sarà
inattiva e quindi non ci saranno effetti
collaterali
bene
arrivati a questo punto del talk un
pochino di scetticismo potrebbe essere
accettabile vi sto parlando di
nanoparticelle che si accendono e si
spengono con i fasci laser e quindi sono
molto da film di fantascienza eppure le
cose stanno così non ci sono dubbi di
esempi illustri abbiamo tantissimi
alcuni addirittura storici il primo
esempio risale al iv secolo dopo cristo
e la magica coppa licurgo perché magica
ecco una coppa che alla luce del sole
appare di questo colore verdino ma se
nell'oscurità mettiamo una candela per
esempio al suo interno
risulta di questo colore rosso e
all'epoca questa era considerata magia
alcuni ritenevano che fosse un dono
degli dei beh oggi noi sappiamo che i
sapienti artigiani romani
inconsapevolmente avevano inserito nella
malvano utilizzata per forgiare questa
coppa una miscela di nanoparticelle
d'oro che appunto sono foto attivabili
si attivano con la luce ed ecco spiegato
l'effetto ottico
tuttavia signori dobbiamo aspettare un
po dobbiamo aspettare il ventesimo
secolo affinché qualcuno
proponga di utilizzare le proprietà
magiche delle nanoparticelle per scopi
medici ea farle un famosissimo
scienziato sono sicuro che meta di voi
in questa sala lo conoscono è un
famosissimo fisico premio nobel si
chiama richards himan e allora facciamo
un altro viaggetto nel tempo stavolta
però andiamo indietro nel passato
c'è un palco come questo al mio posto
c'è il reach al fai ma nessun pubblico
come voi ci sono dei presentatori come
giorgio e federico e allora il
presentatore chiede al famoso scienziato
fine o fai male come si immagina il
21esimo secolo come si immagina la
medicina e la chirurgia nel xxi secolo
la domanda chiaramente pertinente siamo
nel
1960 e allora richard feynman con fare
provocatorio che gli è solito risponde
io immagino xxi secolo senza chirurghi
io immagino che il paziente inghiotta il
chirurgo e che il chirurgo sia in grado
di eseguire l'operazione quindi di
operare il paziente dall'interno
bene e la nascita della nanomedicina è
un concetto così forte attraente che
viene subito ripreso della
cinematografia come spesso succede
infatti in basso a destra trovate la
locandina del film fantastic voyage che
nel 1966 vince il premio oscar per milk
in effetti speciali e parlo appunto di
nanu chirurghi che viaggiano esplora nel
corpo umano la ricerca del patogeno da
eliminare
bene partendo da queste idee visionarie
di richard feynman passando per la
cinematografia che cos'è diventata la
nanomedicina nell'anno 2000 e 21
sicuramente si è sviluppata in
molteplici filone di ricerca
io vi racconto quello di cui mi occupo
più da vicino a cui ho dato il nome di
nanomedicina
programmabile
sapete tutti programmare un sistema vuol
dire aspettarsi un output sulla base di
un determinato input beh programmare una
nanoparticella vuol dire aspettarsi un
effetto terapeutico sulla base di un
determinato stimolo
ora vi voglio raccontare di due progetti
di ricerca che hanno prodotto delle nano
formulazioni attivabili progetti che
sono stati condotti nel laboratorio di
ricerca che io coordino il primo
utilizza un nanotubo di carbonio in un
nome la dice lunga si tratta di una
particella a forma di tubicino
interamente fatta da atomi di carbonio
quello che abbiamo scoperto che questa
particella si attiva con un campo
elettromagnetico come quello prodotto
dai vostri telefonini dagli smartphone è
quello che abbiamo fatto e di mettere in
contatto queste nanoparticelle con i
neuroni che sono le cellule del nostro
organismo responsabile della conduzione
degli impulsi nervosi
lo abbiamo fatto allo scopo di
trasportare dei farmaci all'interno di
questi neuroni nell'animazione vedete
nanotubo di carboni a contatto con le
cellule
vedete al suo interno il materiale
genetico che vogliamo trasferire dentro
le cellule a un certo punto ci sarà
l'accensione del dispositivo che genera
il campo elettromagnetico questo causerà
l'attivazione del nanotubo di carbonio
la sua attivazione
considera una perturbazione locale del
campo elettrico in prossimità del
neurone e l'apertura di minuscoli pori
attraverso le membrane cellulari e sono
questi poli e 32 attraverso i quali
passerà il materiale gen vogliamo
trasferire dentro la cellula
bene signori a questo punto è facile
proiettarsi nel 2050 immaginarsi un
futuro in cui una tecnologia come questa
simile a questa possa essere utilizzata
per trasferire qualunque molecola
all'interno dei neuroni li faccio degli
esempi
molecole che possono curare malattie
neurodegenerative come il parkinson o
l'alzheimer o
materiale genetico per calcolo per
curare le malattie genetiche oppure dei
farmaci chemioterapici per curare tumori
bene capite bene che se fosse davvero
questo se questa speranza fosse attesa
tantissime malattie ad oggi considerate
incurabili avrebbero la loro cura
troverebbero la loro cura
ma passiamo al secondo progetto in
questo progetto utilizziamo delle
nanoparticelle magnetiche
ovvero particelle che sono facilmente
manipolabili con un campo magnetico un
semplice magnete come quelle utilizzate
per scopi decorativi
in questa animazione vedrete anche il
neurone riuscito a distinguere il corpo
cellulare dal lungo prolungamento che
conduce gli impulsi nervosi che si
chiama assone allora immaginiamo di
inserire una miriade di queste
nanoparticelle magnetiche all'interno
della zona quando andremo ad applicare
nostra calamità dall'esterno ecco si
genererà una forza magnetica di
attrazione quello che ha scoperto il mio
gruppo di ricerca che questa forza può
indurre l'allungamento la crescita la
rigenerazione assonale allora vedete
semplice e intuitivo immaginarsi il 2050
e in cui tecnologie simili a queste o
come questa possa essere utilizzare
utilizzate per curare pazienti con
lesioni nervose causate da incidenti
stradali e ferite d'arma da taglio
traumi dal sport
lesioni a lesioni spinali o lesioni a un
nerbo periferico come il marmo mediano e
merlot sciatico bene possiamo
immaginarci un futuro in cui queste
nanoparticelle magnetiche siano assunte
dal paziente tra l'altro sono già
utilizzate nel paziente ma per
trattamenti diversi ad esempio per
curare l'anemia quindi possiamo
immaginare di somministrare queste
nanoparticelle magnetiche al paziente
che poi indosserà un dispositivo
magnetico braccialetto una cintura in
prossimità della ferita ecco questo
consentirebbe la rigenerazione nervosa
sia la rigenerazione di nuovi fascher
sonali come li vedete in questa figura
cosa vorrebbe dire per il paziente
vorrebbe dire recuperare le funzioni
motorie ricominciare a camminare e
ricominciare ad afferrare oggetti
insomma recuperare la funzione motoria
interrotta dall incidente
bene
questi due progetti di cui vi ho appena
parlato sono soltanto due dei tantissimi
interruttori macromolecolari che sono in
corso di progettazione che saranno
progettati nel mio laboratorio di
ricerca in tanti altri laboratori di
ricerca in tutto il mondo allo scopo di
accendere e spegnere un farmaco dove
serve quando serve in un organismo
vivente
e allora vi saluto con il mio sogno
il sogno che i banconi delle farmacie
dell'anno 2050 siano pieni di queste
nano formulazioni attivabili senza
effetti collaterali
ritorniamo per un momento al pensiero di
mere chieda in quella farmacia nell'anno
2050 augura mole auguratemi che questo
mio sogno possa diventare per lei e
chissà anche per tanti altri una
concreta speranza di guarigione
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]